bienvenue à la facture ça vaut la peine
de faire valoir ses droits en cours
parce qu'avec un jugement votre faveur
même les très grandes entreprises
doivent s'incliner et vous payer mais il
est possible que dans la province d'à
côté votre beau jugement ne valent plus
grand-chose voici l'histoire de deux
consommateurs qui ont mis le doigt sur
un gros problème
France Patrick deux consommateurs
déterminés qui se sont battus qui ont
gagné mais qui ont le même problème ils
n'ont toujours pas été payés c'est
frustrant c'est comme si ça donne rien
de s'investir autant
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle un cul-de-sac en
voyant une publicité de la facture ça
m'a donné le goût de vous appeler
bonjour un paquet bonjour c'est Gérard
France paquet et Patrick Gérard ne se
connaissent pas mais ils ont quelque
chose en commun est-ce que des plaques
de ventilation sur le dessus ou c'est
complètement une bordure là qui
exactement on a le même appareil
cinq ans après l'achat l'appareil a
commencé à être défectueux problème de
ventilateur problème électronique et
problème de la plaque à induction le
transformateur explosé
littéralement donc en finir le
réparateur et ça montait une facture de
2100 dollars j'ai amené ça au niveau du
de la côte du Québec j'ai décidé d'aller
à fond dans cette problématique là pour
éviter que notre famille et penser à
travers ces étapes-là d'un produit qui a
pas une durée de vie normale
électrolux a fermé son usine de
l'Assomption en 2014 elle n'a plus
d'établissement au Québec je suis allé
sur un site internet du registre des
entreprises du Québec c'est l'endroit où
on doit avoir une vraie adresse
officielle lorsqu'on dépose une plainte
ou qu'on va la cour des distances faut
vraiment spécifier la bonne adresse et
puis pour Electrolux Canada c'était
vraiment l'adresse en Ontario
à la Cour des petites créances ils ont
tous les deux gagné leur cause alors
j'ai un jugement de
3584 dollars
plus les frais de courts
mais ne pas se présenter en cours ce
n'est pas une façon de s'en sortir une
décision est rendue quand même et le
jugement est acheminé par la poste et
dans ce cas-ci le défendeur a eu 10
jours pour payer moi je pensais que
électrolux aurait
coopérer aurait fait un chèque puis que
j'aurais reçu chaque toute serait bien
passé j'aurais été content c'est là que
France et Patrick ont frappé un mur j'ai
communiqué avec electroluxmaturé qui est
bien reçu le jugement j'aurais écrit de
nouveau tout ça vraiment silence radio
je leur ai réenvoyé quelque chose par
écrit dernièrement puis volontiers on va
s'occuper de ça envoyer nous
j'ai retourné les informations moi j'ai
envoyé mon jugement perdu jugement il y
avait pas de trace je l'ai renvoyé deux
fois quelques mois normal je disais que
j'avais jugement d'appliquer contre les
autres là
aucun signal radio la personne à l'autre
bout à l'eau allô mes écouteurs
fonctionnent pas bien allô
c'est comme les aspirateurs très bon
pour aspirer l'argent mais côté service
on va on va vous poser
si Electrolux était au Québec un
huissier aurait réglé le problème assez
vite merci
au Québec c'est difficile de faire
appliquer le jugement dans une autre
province de forcer l'exécution du
jugement dans une autre province pour
pouvoir faire valoir notre jugement faut
prendre de faire mon loguer au niveau de
l'Ontario parce que c'est une compagnie
qui était bien en Ontario et prendre un
petit de l'Ontario qui ramène encore des
frais par-dessus frais
Electrolux fait-elle exprès de faire
poireauter les consommateurs des autres
provinces pour les décourager
éprouve-t-elle des problèmes
d'organisation nous écrivons à la
directrice des relations publiques si
nous disent ils nous répondent
excuse ça s'est envers deux chaises on
va réparer ça tout de suite quel serait
votre impression face à une réponse
comme ça de leur part ça serait
incroyable c'est impossible que ça tombe
en deux chaises pour mes appels que j'ai
fait
des relances que j'ai refait au complet
j'ai des noms c'est impossible ça aille
tomber de Gex je n'appelle plus je n'y
crois plus alors support service à la
clientèle je n'y crois plus du tout
en attendant une réponse nous prenons la
route vers l'Ontario nous voulons savoir
pourquoi un jugement du Québec doit être
homologué revalider par un autre juge et
surtout combien ça coûte des questions
que nous posons à la présidente de
l'Association du Barreau de l'Ontario
Karen perron
veut juste s'assurer de base que toutes
les procédures ont été suivies que dans
le fond il y a aucune raison pour
invalider le jugement donc un est-ce que
les tribunaux au Québec avaient
compétences d'entendre la faire au
Québec la deuxième chose que le tribunal
ontarien va chercher à confirmer c'est
si le jugement québécois est final il
n'est pas sujet à un appel et
dernièrement le tribunal ontarien va
chercher à valider s'assure que pas de
motifs d'autres publics qui ferait de
sorte qu'on ne devrait pas reconnaître
le jugement Ontario par exemple si
jugement au Québec avait été obtenu par
voie de fraude
en passant l'inverse est vrai aussi les
Ontariens doivent faire reconnaître leur
jugement en se présentant devant la Cour
québécoise il est toujours possible de
se représenter soi-même devant le juge
mais si on veut l'aide d'un avocat sur
place il faut payer je dirais les frais
d'épendent de chaque situation ou dans
même et de façon générale j'irai environ
de 2500 à 3000 dollars puis ça ça serait
pour l'étape numéro 1 donc la
reconnaissance du jugement par la suite
faut exécuter le jugement si on a un
jugement de 1000 dollars est-ce que ça
vaut la peine d'aller faire reconnaître
le jugement au Québec ou en Ontario
contenu des coups potentiels je dirais
non si on a un jugement de 5000 dollars
ou plus ça pourrait valoir la peine ça
dépend vraiment est-ce que il y a des
actifs qu'on peut aller chercher je suis
prête à aller me battre jusqu'au bout
mais de le aller dépenser des sommes
astronomiques pour faire valoir mon
jugement en Ontario un moment
indications je croyais que ça allait
terminer par la suite et j'étais
contente d'avoir été jusqu'au bout alors
qu'aujourd'hui je réalise que c'est pas
terminé
donc on a vu avant la pause que faire
reconnaître un jugement dans une autre
province ce n'est pas facile alors quand
l'entreprise ne s'exécute pas que faire
et bien vous allez voir que 1 vous avez
un allié méconnu mais qui peut vous
aider et deux tout ça pourrait se régler
simplement si nos gouvernements le
voulaient
nous sommes en route vers Granby nous
allons rencontrer une autre personne qui
a eu gain de cause contre Electrolux son
jugement est l'une des 22 décisions que
nous avons trouvé contre l'entreprise
depuis 2018 au Québec
bonjour mes écouteurs bonjour enchanté
vous avez acheté un produit électrolux
oui exact vous avez acheté ça derrière
ici oui service de l'Estrie ok
spécialiste de l'électroménager oui vous
avez gagné à la cour des petits créances
le produit était un problème exact de
compagnie assez important et puis ils
sont venus à au moins trois reprises
changer les différents diverses pièces
et puis ça se staberry que ça
fonctionnait pas alors j'ai été psyché
et puis j'ai gagné j'ai gagné le montant
global de la de l'achat de la cuisinière
qui était 3000 dollars mais qui vous a
payé le détaillant à l'arrière
parce que Pierre Couture a aussi inclu
le détaillant dans sa poursuite selon la
loi celui qui a vendu l'appareil est
également responsable et même si le juge
établit la responsabilité du fabricant à
100% et celle du détaillant à 0%, les
deux sont solidairement responsables du
paiement de la somme lorsque c'est
possible le client a donc intérêt à les
poursuivre tous les deux mais ça bien
des consommateurs l'ignorent
je pensais
à ce niveau là puis c'est pour ça que je
suis allée directement vers Electrolux
je pense que c'est la grande erreur que
j'ai fait
ou ce que j'ai acheté mon appareil en
fait faillite enfermé c'est bon donc je
savais pas personne donc j'ai été
directement chez appeler chez Electrolux
et ce qui est surprenant c'est que la
réponse d’électrolux à ces décisions
semble vraiment aléatoire sur 12
consommateurs qui n'ont pas poursuivi le
détaillant plus de la moitié 7 non pas
été payés seulement 5 ont réussi à
recevoir un chèque pourquoi mystère
je ne comprends pas j'étais tout de même
très surprise et très intriguée de
savoir que certaines personnes avaient
été remboursées alors que
le processus de notre côté et beaucoup
plus laborieux et je dirais une
application comment ça se fait que
certains sont payés
que se passe-t-il chez Electrolux manque
d'organisation nonchalance accord de
tels suffisamment d'importance au
jugement qui arrive des autres provinces
l'entreprise n'a toujours pas répondu à
nos courriels mais il reste un recours
un recours peu connu
c'est certain que le registre des
entreprises peut vous aider dans une
situation comme ça Yves Pépin et le
registreur des entreprises du Québec
c'est obligatoire de s'immatriculer au
registre on n'a pas le choix si je veux
faire des affaires au Québec je dois me
retrouver au Registre des entreprises
lorsqu’une entreprise n'a pas
d'établissement en solde québécois elle
doit obligatoirement déclarer une
adresse pour recevoir des communications
elle peut aussi désigner un fondé de
pouvoir un représentant de l'entreprise
au Québec c'est aussi le cas dans les
autres provinces et dans ce contexte
ceci mais dans une situation de mise en
demeure ou d'entre où on a entreprend
par exemple une procédure légale ben
c'est l'endroit où on doit transmettre
ces
cette information là ces documents là
[Musique]
dans le cas d'électrolux le fondé de
pouvoir est un bureau d'avocat Caroline
WLG situé au centre ville de Montréal
cette information tombe à point pour les
deux clients mais aussi pour nous parce
qu'Electrolux n'a jamais répondu à nos
courriels nous transmettons donc au fond
des pouvoirs les noms de ceux qui n'ont
pas été payés et nos questions pour
l'entreprise à suivre
entre temps nous découvrons un document
étonnant
la proposition d'un comité d'experts la
très discrète conférence pour
l'harmonisation des lois au Canada
j'aimerais ça vous montrer ce document
là
des surprises pour vous aujourd'hui
uniforme sur l'exécution des décisions
et jugements Canadiens est fondé sur le
principe de la reconnaissance totale en
ce qui a très à l'exécution des
jugements entre les provinces et les
territoires du Canada
surpris nous aussi nous avons demandé
des explications au professeur de droit
Guillaume Laganière qui connaît bien
cette loi cadre la loi uniforme c'est
pas une loi qui a été votée par une
assemblée législative ou un parlement
c'est une loi qui émane d'un organisme
d'une organisation qu'on appelle la
conférence pour l'harmonisation des lois
au Canada qui
qui est pas l'idéal
probablement les juridictions soit du
Québec l'Ontario ils veulent pas que un
viennent se mêler des plages juridiction
de l'autre ça protège c'est des grosses
compagnies
pour Patrick Gérard c'est la preuve
qu'il existe un double standard au
détriment du simple citoyen
si
j'ai une contravention en Ontario croyez
moi je vais être obligé de la payer ici
au Québec puis il va avoir des recours
au Québec pour que je paye ma
contravention mais dans
civil malheureusement ça fonctionne pas
de mal
en attendant le fond des pouvoirs nous a
confirmé avoir transmis notre message à
électrolux qui nous a finalement donné
signe de vie nous sommes désolés pour
les inconvénients vécus par ses clients
d'autres provinces et nous revoyons nos
façons de faire afin que ces problèmes
soient résolus en temps opportun et
après des années France pocket Patrick
Gérard et d'autres consommateurs à qui
nous avions parlé ont enfin reçu un
chèque
et pourquoi au juste le Québec et
l'Ontario n'appliquent pas
automatiquement les jugements des autres
provinces à Québec on nous répond que la
question est sous analyse et le
gouvernement de l'Ontario nous répond
lui qu'il craint que ce ne soit pas
équitable pas équitable pour les
antariens mais c'est un argument qui est
inadmissible aux yeux de la conférence
pour l'harmonisation des lois qui
croient au contraire que ce serait bien
plus équitable pour tous les citoyens